it's evident you're not a flashy guy
you're not like you know
but dude you've got to be like just so
wildly successful there's only like you
and violent jay right like in the actual
group i mean we're this whole team of us
you know but like publicly it's just us
too i mean dude it's interesting man
like it was 2004
was it cheers 2000
yeah 2004
and
and um
i uh had the new year's eve it was paris
hilton
birthday for my new year's eve party i'm
partying with kid rock
i've told this story i feel sorry for
you
i'm
sorry right i mean
but it was it was a funny story we did a
lot of cocaine i bet you did yeah and uh
and i remembered saying to kid rock that
i just heard on the radio that for that
year
of 2004 that metallica was like the
biggest grossing i was like i can't
believe the amount of money metallica
made on tour and kid rock looks at me
and says yeah but those [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] split it four ways
he goes you know you want to like you
know
each of those people didn't
touch me i mean like but when you're at
that level does it really matter if
you're splitting it four ways crazy
right and it costs me a stupid [ __ ]
on top of it that's the only thing
well there's a lot of coke involved like
right so who knows it could have been
something right necessary
but but yeah you guys you know
presumably splitting it two ways and so
that that you know i mean
yeah i mean if that was you know the
truth of the matter
if that's how it was cut down and we
were smart about our business actions
and it was cut two ways i'd probably be
sitting real pretty yeah okay all right
you're saying there's like agents
there's people who are managing a lot of
bad decisions
no no i'm saying you don't say that like
like i mean great decisions sure bad
money management or just just i mean
like the gathering for example gathering
juggalos yeah
year's the first year we've ever like
turned a profit on it wow wow ever you
know what i'm saying we're usually
[ __ ] hundreds of thousands of dollars
in the hole every year you know what's
going on so we're so used to losing
money it was nice to turn around and
make some you know and that believe that
didn't get split two ways
yeah but yeah hey don't worry about my
finances right yeah i'm not john i'm not
trying to make you uncomfortable not
trying to make it i mean dude how cool
is that though that the gathering
is still growing like and your guys
whole fan base is still it's like you
haven't even peaked it's fantastic
like i feel like a lot like and this is
no [ __ ] especially like the
everything is so like uh everything's so
like new the horizons are so new now
it's not just touring and putting out
records nowadays it's all this uh
streaming and you don't see any
streaming shows and streaming every
[ __ ] thing you do you know it's just
so it just busts everything wide open
you know and uh
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
dude